roles out now let's bring in the work
and pensions secretary who's with us
this morning hi um you want to tell us
about 600 Quid that's being given to
pensioners how much of a dent is that
going to make on their household energy
bills well it comes within a broader
package of support for the most
vulnerable and I think this has been a
core mission of this government has to
make sure we support people as best we
can if they are vulnerable or less
well-off so there's 650 pounds which has
gone to a million low-income households
300 pounds going out with the winter
fuel payments that's up to 600 pounds
for millions of pensioners a million
pensioners today will actually receive
that amount 150 pounds if you're
disabled 400 pounds off uh energy bills
and of course the energy price guarantee
which means that people are saving on on
average 900 pounds this year on their
energy costs so a huge package of which
pensions are a very important part of it
and bear in mind Kay in the Autumn
statement the chancellor announced
triple lock will be honored going
forward and we've also up rated pensions
by CPI by 10.1 percent and yet civil
sermons so we're hearing this morning
still have to use
food banks
so clearly anybody in a position where
they need to use a food bank is not
right and is something that through time
one would hope that we will get to a
point where nobody needs to use a Food
Bank what the government recognizes is
that as with other countries around the
world we've been really hit very hard by
first the pandemic and then of course by
the war between Ukraine and Russia and
the impact that that's had not just on
energy actually even on foodstuffs and
other products as well which is created
a lot of inflation so given that
backdrop we can't do everything but we
are doing the absolute maximum that we
can whilst getting inflation down and
getting the economy rated so we can get
growth and prosperity moving into the
future and yet people go to the doctor
they're poorly they should be signed off
sick they won't take a sick note because
they have to go to work otherwise they
won't get paid and our prime minister is
spending 250 quid to be able to see a
private GP at the drop of a hat you
understand down the disparity there well
I think as regards the the prime
minister's personal medical Arrangements
I I do think they're a matter for the
Prime Minister but as I say what the
government is absolutely intent on doing
and is doing is making sure that
wherever we can we are helping the most
vulnerable in society so outside of
those direct payments and I've mentioned
we've also just put up the national
living wage by almost 10 percent the
highest increase in the history of the
national living wage we've already
previously made adjustments for example
to the Universal Credit uh taper so that
people keep more of the money as they
move from uh Universal Credit into work
we are providing all sorts of supports
at all sorts of levels but very much
aimed at just the people you're
referring to those who need the help the
most so you don't think it's any of our
business that the Prime Minister can
jump a queue if he needs to go and see
the doctor whereas other people have to
wait to Fortnight well as say I I think
people's personal medical arrangements
are things that if they choose to make
public that's fine but I think it's a
campaigns wasn't it well and we're
totally dedicated there judge him by his
actions and the health secretary's
actions
very difficult
very difficult Autumn statement which
had a lot of very hard choices that had
to be made two things really stood out
one was an increased commitment to
funding education but the other was the
Health Service and social care which
actually got quite a lot of money in the
near term so the commitment that we have
to the NHS is absolutely Central to this
government and that is something that's
very much driven from the top by the
prime okay so it's none of our business
you're saying whether the prime minister
is Private health care well I'm just
saying I think we should respect
people's okay let me ask the fact that
they should be able to let me keep
trying different things do you think
that people who can afford it should pay
to see a GP privately so that other
people don't have to wait a fortnight I
don't think that we should have a
situation regarding the NHS that in any
way interferes with the fundamental
concept of the NHS which is based on
need not ability to pay
if people can afford to pay though
giffen the situation that we found
ourselves in the moment should they take
the lead of the Prime Minister and go
privately
people's decisions on that are are for
people to make individually but as I say
I think the the principle here is that
Arrangements like that are quite rightly
private to those individuals that choose
to take those decisions I don't think
they people should have to publicly
declare exactly what their medical is if
they're a public servant yeah I do I
think that there's a principle here I
mean I understand the sort of line of
questioning that you're pursuing but I
think it's what do you think people are
thinking at home this morning when they
run the doctors and being told their
child is unwell but they have to wait
for a fortnight to sit and then the guy
who's representing them who wants their
vote at the next election can pay 250
quid and and hop in his chauffeur-driven
car and go to the doctors well what I'm
saying very clearly is that when it
comes to the NHS that is an absolute
number one priority for the government
judge the Prime Minister John punch the
government by our actions on that in the
recent Autumn statement huge tough
choices had to be made both on spending
and on taxation but the one area that
got extra support really serious 8
billion pounds worth of extras bought
for social care for example was the
National Health Service so we are
absolutely clear on this we are totally
connected to our NHS we are totally
committed to it being free at the point
of use and that it's available for
everybody on an equal basis with no
queue jumping or anything like that
money will not buy you preferential
treatments on the NHS it'll be there
free at the point of view yeah based on
need what we're going to do about the
rail strikes so I think what's
regrettable is that the trade unions
have come forward with a series of dates
and Strikes now are clearly aimed at
causing maximum uh disruption across the
that's what prescribed Before Christmas
period but before you reach the point of
strikes you should really exhaust all
the other avenues because strikes are
very serious they impact not just
general Journeys but sometimes people to
get back to the medical points that
you're raising who actually need that
transport to get to important medical
appointments for example so what we need
is more engagement and discussion
between those businesses that are
running the railways and network Rail
and the trade unions in order to come to
a balanced realistic outcome and what I
mean by that is it has to be fair to
taxpayers who are funding the railways
and put a lot of money into their
airways during the pandemic not least to
support the jobs of those working within
those Railways but it has to also be
fair to passengers when it comes to the
fairs that they're expected pay and it
has to work with the public finances but
I think the unions need to engage
further on this and we need to not rush
into these strikes
at a time that's really designed to
cause maximum discomfort to the public
what are you going to do about the
transport services Bill why don't you
bring that forward I'm sure you could
get it through the house very quickly if
you decided to as a result there would
be a minimum service that would be
provided yes why is that taking so long
maybe you're so legislation takes a
little while I think sometimes I say
this as a former leader of the house I
used to be responsible for managing
registration yes indeed and the
government has a commitment in that area
and to minimum Service uh provision and
in due course I've no doubt that that
will will come forward and I do think
it's important because I think we
shouldn't be left in position in certain
services such as Railways where we have
such an acute dependence upon them for a
variety of reasons there's no plans to
bring that where the whole thing can
just be the plug can be pulled on the
whole thing but no plan to bring It
Forward I mean well in due course as I
say because it is something that the
government will be will be looking at
then talk to me about a lot of including
former work and pension secretary Chloe
Smith I'm looking at William ragg and
both quite young MPS and yet they're
saying that they're not going to stand
at the next election for your party
what's going on well at every uh general
election there are a number of people
who who step aside uh I think in Chloe's
case I think it's for family reasons she
has young children and she's taken that
decision and I totally respect that I
think what has triggered it in the
immediate term is that the part that the
party has required to basically take a
decision within the next couple of weeks
as to whether they stand or not so I
think you're going to see a lot of those
decisions crystallizing in a very short
period of time a lot of MPS do tend to
step down something like five percent of
the house will step down during every
election but not youngsters like these
two well I I I don't think with with
respect to Chloe and others that they're
the only younger people that have
decided not to fight a a forthcoming uh
election but I think the most important
thing
um add any weight to your argument
well my argument is that people stand
down and uh some of those will be
younger and some of those will be older
and you've cited two examples of uh
relatively uh younger people but the
important things
exactly compared to me I went to the
department at age 47. well there you go
so that was the way I did it
um talk to me about what's going on with
this housing Rebellion there was
supposed to be a vote on getting 300 000
houses built uh a year and quite a few
of your colleagues are saying we don't
agree with that for all sorts of reasons
your boss is worried about losing the
version so he's kicked it into the long
grass okay well I I don't know that any
announcement has been made about
rescheduling of legislation the leader
of the house will come to the house
tomorrow as part of their business day
so it may still go ahead and tell us
more about that yeah the answer is I
don't know we'll have to wait and see
until the leader of the House comes
forward tomorrow so what I'm reading in
the papers is wrong on that well the
papers are sometimes right okay and some
sometimes they are wrong we'll get the
answer to that essay question tomorrow
it's like a sieve
um will you use taxpayers money to have
a Christmas party this year definitely
not definitely not okay I'm and I think
what would you say to other MPS who are
thinking of doing well I I it's for them
to decide but look let's be clear about
what's happened here okay the the
general view I think out there is the
MPS have somehow designed things so that
they're able to charge the taxpayer for
Christmas parties and decorations and
drinks and things like that that could
not be further from the truth ipsa which
is an independent body has taken that
decision it certainly wasn't done yeah
um yeah yes so it then becomes a case of
then do individual energy so what would
you say to individually well my decision
I I try to avoid lecturing other MPS as
to what they should do I mean there's
certain circumstances I certainly would
do that but I think on this yeah
everybody has to take their own judgment
my firm view is that in my case I will
not be doing that I don't think it sends
the right signal I don't actually think
that it's as decision is the right one
and I know that a number of my
colleagues share that view and are quite
what's the word quite upset about the
fact actually that ipsa has put all
maintenance in a position where the
public is saying well you're all up to
spending our hard-earned money on your
Christmas celebrations and that's not
right I suspect the vast majority of MPS
would agree with that but we've been put
in that position
what decision will have you celebrating
um at the Supreme Court today what do
you want to hear well I I think what we
want to hear is is just the results of
their conclusions which will be at 9 45
this morning I don't think it'd be right
for me to stop pre-judging that or
saying well if it's this I think this or
if it's that I think something
differently I think we have to wait to
see what they come forward really
I do I think well it's a big moment
um there's been you know the government
put its case I think last month um uh
with with Vigor other case your other
arguments have been put forward we now
need to give the judges just a little
bit of extra space to come forward later
this morning and then let's let's talk
about what this is okay what do you
think of the football
uh this is the sale of Ronaldo is it
Manchester United Manchester United yeah
well I I think at the end of England you
prefer well I I think these are
commercial decisions
um I don't personally think it's for
government to weigh in on two
frequencies the Saudis buy it
um well
I you know as I said something else this
morning yeah one night I just don't I
don't think that you know we're always
urged as governments sort of get
involved in all sorts of areas of of
sports and and I think that's just one
which I I might resist okay but you did
watch the England yeah I did and I
thought we were terrific and it was a
great result and uh you know Harry Kane
needs to see it has crossed sorry
hurricane needs a scan on his ankle
right well that's that's not that's a
fly in the ointments
but who knows you know I've just got a
good feeling about England this time and
Wales of course too who did very well
okay it's great to see you as always
thanks very much thank you